hope every one of you can see my screen
and can hear me out well so we are going
to deal with two important resources
during the program the first one is the
edu dot T - bio dot info I hope that
every one of you have to login
credentials for the edu dot e - bio info
please try the try it out to login and
if there is any technical difficulty
please let us know either by writing
down on the chat box or you could unmute
yourself so we would be utilizing the
edu dot T - Bharat info for all our
courses projects and the organization
page so once you log in you could see
that you could see the name of your link
profile and the profile picture if you
have one over here if you hover down
there are courses since you're the part
of the program so all the courses would
be made available to you we have the
basic courses that starts from
introduction to bioinformatics
introduction to genomics and a more
technical course that is genomics one
she could play around with those those
courses and try to go through the
content of the course is just so that
you know you have a better understanding
about what all is going on in the
lectures over here we do have the
projects we would be utilizing some of
these projects during our lecture and at
the end of the program the participants
would be required to work on the
independent project so you could have an
idea about the projects and how are they
designed by going under the projects tab
on the edu site the other thing that I
wanted to show you is the organization
page so what exactly is an organization
page organization page is a personalized
dashboard that has been created for all
the participants of the rmx logic
genomics program so if you come down at
the bottom over here you could see
organization and under that you could
see
seis genomics training so that's how
you're going to access the organization
page so if you click on that you would
be redirected to a new page and this is
the this is how the organization page is
going to look over here you could see
that we have different tabs home forum
progress curriculum assignment and the
courses that would be involved all the
important updates about the program or
the program would be there on this
organization page so for example you're
going to have all the events that we are
going to cover on the events tab over
here and then the recording the
presentation that is used for the
session and the remote access link
everything would be available over here
on the activity page so all the
important updates would be they're
posted on the organization page so it
would be nice if you keep yourself
updated with all those information under
the forum we would have all the
recordings and all the presentations or
the data set that is being used in the
in the session everything you can find
it under the forum you can see that
there is one forum that was created by
Ilia to welcome all the participants
other than that if the participants have
anything to share like a research
article or their thoughts their ideas
feel free to open a new topic under the
forum or if you have any questions you
can put it up and then we or the other
participants could answer it in the
forum so that you know everything is
there under the forum then moving
forward to the progress tab so for each
and every activity that you're going to
do on the edu site or on the T bio info
platform we do assign the points for the
same and then you could see the progress
of each and every participant that what
are they doing and what are they up to
over here under the progress tab
so I would like to explain more about
the point system so let's say that you
know if you are on the edu side and if
you go ahead and take any of the courses
let's say introduction to genomics so
once you register for a course you would
be assigned 400 points if you complete
the course you will be given 500 points
if you run the pipeline's on the t-bar
infor platform then you will be given
some certain points so that's how we are
going to track the progress of each and
every participant and just to make sure
that you know all the participants are
moving forward on the same page so this
was overview about the organization page
and the edu site as a whole then the
second resource that we are going to
deal with is the T bio info platform and
the URL is server dot T - bio dot info
the credentials for the debugging for
platform was emailed to all the
participants yesterday so please make
sure that all of you are able to login
to server dot T - pi dot info if there
is any difficulties technical
difficulties logging in or if if you're
not able to log in please feel free to
let us know so we would be utilizing the
T by info platform for all our practical
exercises
it has different sections including NGS
data of mass spec structure biology and
data integration and modeling if you
would like to know more about those
sections you can just hover around on
that section and there would be a pop-up
that would let you know what exactly is
that section going to cover in the in
the platform we have two different kind
of pipelines one is the actual pipeline
that you would be running when you're
working with the real data and the other
one is the demo pipeline so the demo
pipelines will be utilized during these
sessions so that you know you could play
around with those pipelines and you get
a better understanding of each and every
algorithm and what kind of an output
file you can expect from every algorithm
so I would like to show you both the
demo pipeline and that
pipeline so if you go under the section
of genomics epigenetics you could see
that there are a couple of pipelines
that are listed over here so if you go
ahead and click on mutation variant over
here you're gonna see that there's a pop
up that would tell you what exactly is
the mutation variant you could read
about it there's a publication that
would let you allow to go in depth about
what exactly is the mutation variants so
you can go ahead and read more about it
if you're interested so this is the
actual pipeline I'm not gonna go deeper
today because it's an introductory class
so I just wanted to give you an overview
so this is the actual pipeline that you
would be utilizing it later in the
program so you have a couple of
parameters over here that you need to
make the selections from once you do the
selection then you can go ahead and
start the pipeline but just to give a
more clear understanding about the
pipeline I'm gonna go back and I'm gonna
use the demo pipeline so if you go under
mutation variant and there's a drop down
over here it says demo variant calling
so I'm gonna go and click on this over
here I don't have to worry on any
parameters I can just click on start and
as soon as I'm going to click on start
it's gonna give me overview of what
exactly is demo pipeline
what's mutation what is this pipe I'm
going to do and how you going to analyze
a genomic data so we do try to educate
and reiterate at each and every level so
whatever algorithm you're gonna select
there would be a pop up that would give
you a brief idea about what that
algorithm does and what's the input and
the output file that you can expect so
I'm gonna click OK after clicking ok
clicking start I could see that there
are several highlighted button the those
buttons are the algorithms that you
could utilize so let's say that I have a
genomic data and I wanted to the
pre-processing of my data so how
would I be able to do the pre-processing
over here you could see there's a
section that says data pre-processing so
this section is dedicated for
pre-processing of my data so in this I'm
gonna select PCR clean so it would give
me an formation about what exactly is
PCR clean I'm gonna click on OK and then
this an option to map so I can map using
bowtie - you wanna click on OK over here
it's gonna give me what exactly is
bowtie and the publication if you would
like to read more about bowtie gonna
click on OK and then I'm gonna see if I
would like to use something else over
here I have an option under differential
variant calling to use the algorithm
straight Strelka so we can go ahead and
click on this so once you go back to the
edu site and you're going to take the
courses of introduction to genomics and
genomics one you wanna have a better
understanding about what all these
algorithms do and what's the
significance of these algorithms so
that's how you're gonna create your own
pipeline and then once you are done with
the pipeline you're gonna click on end
and then that's where you're gonna get
the output files so that's the logic
behind having the demo pipeline so that
you could play around with it you don't
have to worry about the input files
everything is there it says for the
practice purposes and you don't have to
wait for the pipeline's to get over with
the demo pipelines so those are some of
the benefits of the demo pipelines the
last thing that I would like to mention
is on the edu site you do have an option
to update your profile if you go under
if you click under the under your name
on the top border there is an option
that says profile it's very important if
you could complete your profile and what
I mean with completing the profile is to
have a good profile picture to have
social media links and some background
information about you so that the
participants can know who are who is the
other person and with whom are they
having this program so that you know
they can reach out to you they can talk
about projects they can talk about
collaborations so the idea is to build a
close community
where
could discuss all the opportunities all
the ideas of related to by informatics
related to genomics data analysis and
things like that so I would like to show
you some of the examples of the good
profiles I would say the first one I
would like to highlight is Cowan you
could see that she has a good profile
over here she has around eleven thousand
points and as I mentioned initially that
for each and every activity that you do
on edu site and on the T by info
platform you're gonna get the points for
and that's why it says over here that
she has eleven thousand points she has a
profile picture over here and if you go
under yeah and you could see that all
the activities are listed over here that
she did start the pipeline and then if
she finished a specific pipeline and
then all the participants of the omics
logic program would have a badge that is
assigned to to them so that means like
you know you're the part of that
specific organization so Cowan is the
part of the precision oncology program
and that's why she has this program we
do have a good profile from one of our
participant today in our mix logic it's
for Amit so you could see that he has a
profile picture he has a badge and he
did try running some of the pipelines so
these are some of the examples of good
profile so it would be nice if you can
go back and complete your profile and in
the last I would like to highlight
profile for despina so we could see that
she has she has all the information
about her
what is she has been doing what's the
position her social media link
she has 19 thousand points and then she
is the part of the organization omics
logic and that's why she has the badge
over here and then you can directly go
out and check her LinkedIn profile as
well so now I would like to ask despina
to come on the stage and introduce her
and
few words about her hello everyone my
name is destiny ikkaku first of all I'd
like to wanted to what welcome one of
you to the almost logic genomic project
program I have to say that it is a great
pleasure for me to guide you through the
program and ok let me take you a little
bit about the program so for the next
weeks we will go through some basic and
more advanced concepts of genomics data
analysis by the end of the course you
will have gained the necessary knowledge
and resources to design your own
analysis of genomics data but this stone
will be presented to you after
afterwards and let me tell you about my
excuse me is someone talking I can see
you peni speaking if someone is unmuting
I mean can you just mute your microphone
so that despina can speak thank you ok
so ok I am from Greece I have a
background in computer science I
graduated from department of computer
science at the University of Athens I
continued my studies for my master's
degree in bioinformatics at the same
Department and C's since 2016
I am the bioinformatician of molecular
diagnostics laboratory at Democritus
Democritus is the largest scientific
research center in Greece so in our lab
molecular diagnostics lab we study
hereditary cancer molecular diagnostics
lab is a reference lab in Greece for
heretic dancer we have been studying
hereditary cancer since 1998 at first by
studying specific genes that were known
to predisposed to hereditary cancer
syndromes
while seems 2014 with the help of
next-generation sequencing technology we
have static more genetically sie which
we don't know yet if they are if
mutations in this ruse I are responsible
for heritage records so in the lab I am
the only by fermentation among among
geneticist and I am responsible for all
the bioinformatics pipelines and
analysis performed our goal is to
decipher the mutational spectrum of
hereditary cancer in Greece up until now
we have analyzed more than 10,000 cancer
patient families while almost 6000 of
them are analyzed by next generation
sequencing so in parallel
I am conducting my PhD studies at the
University of Thessaloniki and my goal
might be its this goal is to develop
bioinformatics tools and algorithms in
order to analyze data and identify
genetic biomarkers that will diagnose
hereditary cancer and maybe help
patients benefit from targeted therapies
so for the next week me with pro team
until that you see in the screen and
here we will guide you through genomic
analysis and I hope that you will all
have fun and learn many things thank you
thank you very much to subpoena and say
he'll and everybody is appreciating the
effort that we're putting in to make
this program successful for you and I
briefly wanted to touch on the point of
what might be the outcome why you would
benefit from going through the online
materials and through the practical
aspects of the program and again review
some of the topics that we will be
covering at any point in time feel free
to add your questions or comments in the
chat we do want to hear
your opinions or any questions and make
sure that we address those in a timely
way we have a chat box as you have seen
both the platform and on the educational
site and you please can feel free to
communicate with us sometimes we will
ask you what is your email ID and what
is your name and that is just for us to
help community connect your question
with your account and see you know what
we can add to the program if anything so
I do want to just also add that we are
recording these sessions every time
after the session after several maybe
hours we will be posting the recorded
version of this webinar on the forum so
don't worry you will get the recording
if you miss one of these sessions you
will still get the recording and all
that information is going to be
available on that program page that say
he'll already showed you so as you see
we have several people here we have
Sahil who will be dealing primarily with
the organizational aspect of the program
this Pina is really the bioinformatics
expert that has the experience and
analysis of genomic data and she will be
guiding you to understand that
theoretical aspects of some of these
analysis methods and giving you some of
those examples and ProTeam who also has
a lot of experience in bioinformatics
and is at the same time teaching several
other programs that we are conducting he
will be here to answer any questions
facilitate the discussion and help
provide additional materials
publications or other materials that
would be helpful for you to appreciate
the way that genomic data is making a
difference in cancer and a variety of
other conditions that we will be talking
about in this program so what is
genomics in the context of this omics
logic program the Onyx logic
program was established to cover four
main areas of onyx that we have
identified as a primary interest for a
lot of the people that we have been
interacting with and that are critical
for the understanding of the way that
molecular data is impacting a variety of
areas from infectious disease to
oncology to agriculture and to
neuroscience and other areas where
research is producing a lot of
interesting discoveries and a lot of
those discoveries are also translational
to the field of medicine biotechnology
pharmaceutical industries etc so the
omics quadric program covers the area of
genomic data transcriptomic data
epigenomic data and metagenomic data and
typically the way that these programs
are structured their anywhere between
two and three months depending on the
type of audience and we have already
been testing this program in a variety
of universities at different levels at
the undergraduate level at the graduate
level and of course we work with a lot
of industry professionals as well as
researchers the goal of the program is
to empower you to do your own research
be able to analyze your own data and
have the theoretical understanding of
both the methods the type of data and
the applications of this data in a
variety of industry and research
applications so as we start off with
very basic ideas to refresh our memory
about what is DNA what is DNA code how
can we analyze that type of information
we are really trying to help facilitate
a process where you are familiar with
the type of information that you might
be dealing with you can start asking
questions of that data and eventually
develop a whole project either using
data that you already have
that you have generated yourself in your
lab or your collaborators or using
publicly available or public domain data
which will also show you where you can
find and how you can download and help
you upload it to the platform so that if
you do not have the infrastructure to
analyze some of these larger datasets
you will be able to do that as well so
again the goal is to give the
theoretical background but fairly
quickly to jump into the practical
aspect allowing you to work
independently and if you are not ready
to work on a project independently help
you find another project that maybe
somebody else is working on so that you
can get plugged into that project and
get something practical out of this
program we are conducting a number of
sessions that will be much more focused
on various aspects of genomics you might
have questions related to some algorithm
that we haven't covered or you might
have a specific question about a project
obviously there's a variety of resources
that we can point you to or help you
find so that we can answer those
questions but let us go through quickly
the topics that we found to be important
to cover in this program just one by one
and kind of explain a little at how this
will be structured so first of all I
want to say that we have scheduled to
approximately two meetings per week so I
will be going through some of these but
of course this is not a comprehensive
list and then at the end of this I will
show you where you can find all of this
material we have a previous recording
where you can see the topics that we
will cover that we covered in the free
webinar and we also have all of this
information on the genomics program tab
that say heal just showed so we will
start today introduction to the program
we kind of give you a program overview
of tools and resources
some of the expectations again the
expectation is that all of you will feel
comfortable enough to analyze your own
data and now we will go through the
materials and you already got introduced
to the speakers and the presenters in
the program and so we hope that this
will be a two-way conversation an
interactive session as well as a lecture
that you can benefit from so first of
all we will talk about DNA and the code
that a DNA has what are these letters
you know different genomes that are out
there we will be focused a lot on the
human genome but not only we will also
look at genomes of for example viruses
or bacteria and we will talk about the
different types of genomes and what do
we need to keep in mind as we look at
these different genomic data so we will
also look in detail at the different
technologies sequencing technologies
that have been developed over time and
primarily we will focus on the next
generation sequencing technology that
produces short reads and those short
reads have to be mapped on that
reference genome to be able to identify
which part of the genome did they really
come from so we will talk about the DNA
the DNA a structure the variants the
chromosomes and then we will also talk
about how these different sequencing
methods help us identify variants and
see what might be the significance of
those variants then we will start
talking about processing this data and
so when we say processing genomic data
what we mean is structuring that data
because first of all we get access to
raw large datasets that really are deep
to sift through if we want to identify
something of significance for our
analysis so what we will cover there
again are the different types of
sequencing and that's important because
that gives us an idea into what kind of
information we will be able to find but
also some technical aspects like the
read links the mapping different mapping
techniques and how to select the right
reference genome of course and what we
will see is that there are actually many
many different techniques that utilize
the same next-generation sequencing
technique but really are designed to
show us different type of information so
what you can see here again is a chart
over the years you can see an explosion
of methods and short sequence aligners
for DNA RNA methylation and micro need
it is a variety of data types a variety
of different types of information that
we can extract from this and the basic
idea that we will first focus on is how
do we align this data to the reference
genome and then how do we visualize it
now any type of fast queue data you can
put into an aligner and it will align it
to the reference genome and we'll talk a
little bit about the different types of
sequencing also some of the ones that
you are mentioning in the chat PacBio
Oxford nanopore so different types of
sequencing that are not traditional next
generation sequencing like Illumina does
but we will talk about these different
sequencing techniques in the context of
how does that impact our ability to
align them to the reference genome and
then vision belies the results and then
we'll briefly talk about the overall
idea behind processing of this data so
for example we first do pre-processing
eliminate some additional
actors or amplification of reeds and
what would be the impact of
pre-processed being on specifically
genomic data we'll talk about the
different techniques for mapping
visualization is a step that is helpful
but not critical for the analysis itself
but we will go into that aspect as well
we'll talk about the variant calling and
how we utilize statistical approach just
to differentiate between noise and the
different types of variants and then
we'll jump into the analysis for example
differential analysis or other type of
analysis and finally annotation how do
we annotate and all of that is
encapsulated in the platform and the
goal is to really help you jump into the
analysis quickly and not spend the time
to install all the different packages
and set up your environment first to
learn how to how does it work and then
if you desire to do that on your own we
will be happy to assist you with that as
well
so then we'll jump into additional
aspects of the processing and I do want
to just show you a quick example of this
pipeline so sahil already showed this
but just quickly to give you an overview
really the goal is to eliminate any kind
of technical difficulty and as you build
your pipeline to learn about the impact
of your different selections that you
are doing and then quickly see the
result what is the output and then how
can we evaluate the output of multiple
types of techniques and really see what
would be the result of that analysis so
that is really the goal of this initial
step to reduce everybody into that
asks us the data having to go through
several steps to get that data to be
useful for announces and once we
understand that then what we will go
into are the different types of DNA
variation and of course the different
methods that we would need to use to
identify those ways the DNA could vary
from for example the reference genome or
from a normal sample that is from the
same organism so we'll talk about
different types of mutations for example
germline mutations somatic mutations
like the ones that arise in cancer as a
result of cell division and we'll talk
about other non point variations of copy
number variation so what we felt was
important for us is to give a broad
overview of a variety of different DNA
variation types but then to go closer
and look at how those types could be
interpreted in the context of a project
so we'll spend a little bit more time we
actually have several parts for some of
these bigger topics and specifically
when we talk about DNA variation we'll
see how the different types of variants
will specifically focus a little more
time spend on the single point
variations and we'll talk about how
different types affect essentially in a
different way the product of whatever is
encoded in the DNA and as a result of
our ability to look at the different
types of variants we will look at how
it's important to understand both the
biology of DNA code a transcription of
that DNA code into RNA and then
translation of that RNA into protein the
central dogma of biology but also we
look at how just technically these
variants have an impact on what we are
trying to analyze and so we will you
visualization including visualization in
J brows that is a part of the platform
as well as other visualization
techniques where we can start
incorporating more information into what
we are seeing for example when we map
our reads and we identify genes that are
there in the GTF file how can we add add
additional information about the
variants and the common for example
single nucleotide polymorphism database
that will give us an idea of what is
known about a specific position or how
we can use reference studies for example
the Cancer Genome Atlas TCGA to
understand in what other cases has a
specific mutation been studied and
associated with a specific outcome so
that will bring us to the point of being
able to analyze some of these genomic
variants because if you think of the
length of the DNA the 3 billion base
pairs and you think of the amount of
variants which is typically we think of
about 1% of our DNA having significant
variation 1% of 3 billion is a lot of
variants so there is a lot of room for
us to get stuck in just a lot of data
and we don't know what to do with a lot
of that data so we will talk about how
we can for example filter some variants
and focus on a specific type of variant
or a specific selection of variants
we'll talk about how we can leverage the
coverage and when we talk about some of
these different sequencing techniques
when we talk about whole genome
sequencing whole exome sequencing
targeted sequencing some of these long
read methods like PacBio
or low-quality like Oxford nanopore how
does the impact of the error rate and
the impact of the length of the read the
coverage of the read how do all of those
aspects factored in to our ability to
analyze in a statistical way the
variance that we have identified for
significance and use that to understand
the difference between our samples so
we'll talk about that again we'll spend
some more time actually a couple of
meetings will be dedicated to that and
we will talk about that these variants
they essentially effect and help
categorize the mutations in terms of
what they would mean so when we talk
about that we'll talk about
missense mutations nonsense mutations
frameshift mutations and we'll see how
these ways of categorizing mutations are
actually going to help us focus on a
specific type of variance that we are
going to be discussing in the context of
a project as I already mentioned we can
now use this information to annotate and
now we can understand what's in our data
and try to bring it closer to more of a
biological understanding of what's going
on for example we can start looking at
specific variants that are affecting the
genes in a specific way and then
abundance of those mutations associated
with a specific type of a condition how
do we leverage all of this information
of being able to filter the variants
being able to focus on a specific type
being able to then leverage databases
and reference studies and tie all of
that together and sometimes we will look
at efforts databases as maybe one so to
say supervised direction and we will
look at more Association studies like
for example genome-wide Association
studies when we have a phenotype and a
genotype and we need to understand the
relationship between them
so all of these things will be covered
first in the context of the platform
because the platform really all that it
does is it puts the different methods
together in a way that we can all follow
along and produce a result and then in
each method as you have seen Sahil has
pointed out each method is described in
detail a lot of times with the code that
you can download and we'll show you some
examples of that and then you'll be able
to set up that pipeline independently
but of course that is not the focus or
the part of the course itself the course
is not going to be training you how to
set up the pipeline it's going to be
focused on understanding the methods
understanding the types of challenges
and the opportunities that genomic data
provides and being able to leverage that
to work independently on or on your
project so but we can talk about that if
you're interested in the aspect of
technical understanding of the methods
and how to make them work we can talk
about that as well of course somebody
like the spinner in her lab has to
regularly set up pipelines to process
and annotate some of the data that
they're working with so I'm sure that
she will be able to speak to that from
her experience now we will also look at
some of these repositories and databases
that are regularly used in the analysis
of specific types of mutation data so
for example as you can understand the
types of reference databases and studies
for cancer are going to be very
different from let's say infectious
diseases or you know raizo bacteria from
the roots of plants so there are going
to be a variety of different types of
databases and resources that we will
cover and we will talk about how do you
find a data set that you will be able to
use in the context of your project and
how do you
invalidate what is the validity of some
database and how reliable is that source
so we'll talk about some of those
aspects and then we'll talk about pure
databases that just have all of this
information collected in a specific way
that you can query or simply collection
of data sets that we can use as
reference and so we'll talk about some
of that and the way we would like to do
this is really ty there's two the the
project that you are working on so
really if you are starting to think of a
data set you're starting to think of a
project that you have been working on
and you are starting to formulate your
question in terms of the types of
methods that we have covered the sooner
we can start having that conversation
the quicker we can get that process
started and hopefully all of us will
benefit from working in a real use case
scenario and not just theoretical
knowledge that you know becomes very
impractical when you face specific
challenges an important aspect of
analysis is not just the annotation and
the filtering which is a standard
approach but also using statistical
methods machine learning methods that
help us identify relationships in
complex datasets so when we talk about
specifically genomic data we are meaning
a very specific type of data it's
different for example from
transcriptomic data or from metagenomic
data and a lot of our ability to analyze
this type of data in a nonlinear fashion
in a fashion that really incorporates
the complexity is first preparing that
data in a very specific way so up until
this point we have been dealing with
processing or preparing that data for
our ability to analyze it and as we said
that will include the pre-processing
steps the mapping the annotation
for example annotation by gene or
annotation by type and then preparing
essentially a table but once you have
that table then you're able to deploy
some of these more complex machine
learning techniques that could be
supervised or unsupervised and a lot of
these techniques are now being used in
profiling of patients for example
stratification of patients
identification of signatures and
associating those signatures of
selecting specific positions or specific
types of mutations or specific levels of
mutation abundance with a specific
phenotype and we'll look at how this is
used in biomarkers as well as some other
use cases for example in the development
of vaccines for infectious diseases so
really a lot of different exciting
applications of machine learning for
genomic data but of course because it's
genomic data we have to be very specific
about how do we prepare the data and
what does it look like and then this
will also guide our ability to
understand the machine learning output
and interpretation of the results so
again because this is a complicated
topic and it requires some understanding
and some practice we will actually spend
a whole three sessions to talk about
machine learning and some of the things
that we will be talking about are for
example unsupervised techniques like
principal component analysis that can
very nicely summarize the data about
samples based on genomic variance and
based on other aspect for example
abundance of mutation in a whole genome
so we'll talk about some of these
techniques and we'll talk about how
these techniques are used in a specific
project as an example as you can see
here we see a timeline of Ebola the
outbreak of Ebola as you can remember
the previous outbreak of Ebola in 2014
2016 was a very interesting of course
dangerous to vent that happen and forced
us to understand try to understand how
the genomes of these individual viruses
developed over time and how can we
associate them with the location with
the violence and with the outcome how
lethal how pathogenesis of that virus
changed because of those mutations and
now because we were able to utilize
sequencing in real-time sequencing data
from patients taking samples from
patients and culturing them see being
how these techniques can really inform
our ability to intervene our ability for
example the vaccine the Ebola vaccine
that is now being used in Africa in the
current outbreak was developed as a
result of that previous outbreaks we
will look at that example project will
look at machine learning techniques in
the context of that project and as you
can see here machine learning of course
has a variety of applications and a
variety of topics that will be covered
inside of this broad kind of a topic of
machine learning
finally we will transition to some of
the projects and the projects are of
three kinds one kind are the projects
that we have prepared and so some of the
examples you can see here cancer studies
where we will look at hereditary
mutations that are contributing to the
risk level of how risk how much risk is
there for a patient to develop a
specific cancer and we'll look at
somatic mutations how we can detect
early onset of cancer or for example
understand the staging understand the
type etc
we'll talk about tuberculosis which of
course is another interesting area for
many groups around the world studying
MTB specifically where there is a
resistance to different treatments and
we'll try and look at how we can detect
resistance in microbial infections and
how we can associate them for example
with the source where they came from and
this is of course an important topic and
we'll kind of touch on that in this
course we'll talk about case control
studies and genome-wide Association
studies and also we'll talk as I
mentioned about other types of non-human
diseases or non-human genome so some of
these examples are right here the
somatic mutations in cancer the drug
resistance and tuberculosis viral
adaptation in Ebola and an example with
genome-wide associations that he's using
raisa bacteria but also some other
examples as well and so we do want you
to know that you know the reason we are
starting this program now in the summer
and the reason that we are excited about
this is also because we are doing this
specific program for the first time and
we have done it in the constant of other
types of programs where genomics was
only a component and not the full
program but this specific genomics
program and we are doing it for the
first time and I really wanted to say
that we appreciate a lot the work that
the spino proteins to heal and others
have put into this program it's we are
still finalizing some final touches and
preparing some materials so please keep
that in mind but you know we do think
that we have some great content that is
ready to be shared with you and we are
excited to see the projects that you
have and of course a lot of these
projects they are research projects
right and so research projects do not
always yield concrete answers or yields
very clear results and there's always an
aspect of being both an understanding
we have to come to these projects with
an understanding of what we are trying
to get out of a project what is exactly
our question we have to come at it from
an understanding of the tools that we're
using how these tools work what are the
parameters that we can adjust for these
tools to work properly how do we combine
these tools together to give us the
answer to the question that we are
looking for and then finally how to
interpret what do we do with the results
of these methods how do we look deeper
than just what first appears on the
surface how can we also be critical of
the results of the analysis and how can
we ask ourselves with where the results
are not only satisfactory for us to give
us a broad idea of what's going on but
really how do they answer the question
that we first originally posed so we'll
talk a lot about these aspects of
research in these projects but also we
will talk about some of the exciting
translational of these projects for
example we saw that disp in his lab just
in June I had a publication come out and
have some results from the analysis of
the data that they have and we'll talk
about how it's important to generate
some of these hypotheses maybe utilizing
public domain data but then a lot of the
ability to publish and to have these
conclusive studies is also the data that
you have access to so we'll talk about
some of the significance of the data
types the data sources the amount of
data that you should have in a study
that is impactful and conclusive so
again those are some of the aspects of
the program the schedule the topics that
we will cover the project examples and
of course you are not limited to the
projects that we are preparing for this
program you are also welcome to work on
your own projects come with your own
datasets or leverage some of these
public domain repositories where we will
show you how to find
data that might be relevant to the topic
that you're studying so I do want to
again highlight the people that will be
your primary connections
despina who is really an expert in the
clinical genomics and bioinformatics
from a computational side point ProTeam
who has a lot of experience and is doing
right now a lot of program planning and
interaction with all of you say he'll
who knows the platform and knows the
educational resources that we have and
of course I'll be joining this program
as well at this point I really want to
spend the next several minutes that we
have left for questions and answers and
I welcome per team
despaigne uh Sahil any of you to add to
what I have covered before and any of
you that are part of this program we
want to mention that you know we're
excited to see what you can produce
during the program and if you have any
questions or if you have any comments on
what we've had so far
please either add them on chat or you
can unmute yourself often and speak and
we'll be happy to answer any of that